una asamblea nacional que nos respalda
casi completamente se posesionará para
un quinto mandato el presidente
nicaragüense daniel ortega junto a su
esposa y vicepresidenta rosario murillo
este domingo la asamblea perteneciente
en su mayoría al oficialista frente
sandinista de generación nacional tomó
posesión nuestra guía va a ser siempre
buscar la independencia
defender la soberanía de nuestro país
defender la autodeterminación del pueblo
nicaragüense el presidente de la
asamblea nacional que está en este cargo
desde hace cinco años está sancionado
por eeuu y canadá por promulgar leyes
represivas además el departamento del
tesoro sancionó a otras nueve personas y
al ministerio público de nicaragua pero
para algunos analistas las acciones van
en contra del pueblo nicaragüense
lamentablemente la persona internacional
juega a favor de personajes como daniel
ortega porque le dan la oportunidad de
encontrar la misma de todos los males
del país esta situación de aislamiento
paradójicamente hará que ortega
permanezca en el poder por mucho tiempo
así como en cuba o en el partido
gobernante razón las polémicas
elecciones de noviembre donde siete
posibles candidatos presidenciales de la
oposición fueron detenidos por las
autoridades antes de los comicios en la
asamblea nacional sólo 16 de los 91
escaños son de la oposición el partido
gobernante tiene el control de los otros
75 puestos con este panorama y sin
contrapeso ortega tendrá el respaldo
interno para iniciar un gobierno más de
cinco años